على ملعب تنطلق اليوم اولى مباريات الدوري
نصف النهائي من مونديال قطر الارجنتين
وكرواتيا هذه المباراه الثالثه التي تجمع
المنتخب بين في نهائيات كاس العالم
الفريقان تجاوز الدور السابق بركلات
الترجيح حمامه هولاندا والبرازيل وفي حال
وصول المباراه الى ركلات الترجيح من
المحتمل ان نشاهد مباراه اخرى فاكله
الحارسين بارعين في التصدي وكرواتيا لم
تخسر ابدا في تلك الركلات في مشاركاتها
بالمونديال ميسي يريد هو اللقب الاهم في
مسيرته الوحيد الغائب عن انجازاته اما
الان والا انتهى لا فرصه اضافيه ومرتش
قائد كرواتيا يريد تعويض خيبه امل مونديال
روسيا عندما خسر فريقه امام فرنسا في
النهائي لكن ليكن صريحين القصه كل القصه
هي ميسي هل يتوج ميسي في اثمن جائز على
وجه الارض قبل ان ينهي مسيرته الموندياليه
اذهب معكم الى القاهره حيث سالنا الجماهير
عن توقعاتها بمباريات نصف نهائي المونديال
متابعه
[موسيقى]
المغرب والارجنتين كلنا كعرب نفسنا المغرب
طبعا ياخذ البطوله المغرب عامله مونديال
حلو طبعا اتمنى يعني تعالوا النهائي باذن
الله باذن الله المغرب هتحمل كاس العالم
تكسب بس هي فرنسا اللي هتكسب الارجنتين ان
شاء الله
الدوحه ينضم لنا في هذا الشهر المراسل
صباح العربيه فهد اهلا بك كيف هي
التحضيرات والاستعدادات لمباراه الارجنتين
كرواتيا
مرحبا صباح الخير للاعدادات الاستعدادات
على اعلى وتيره على اعلى حماس بالامس وصلت
اربع طائرات ارجنتينيه طبعا هو مو ناقصين
اللي هنا العدد كبير جدا الجمهور
الارجنتيني الان الاعلى معه بجانب الجمهور
المغربي
طبعا المنطقه الي امامنا هنا امتدادها
منطقه اكبر منطقه جماهيريه اللي هي سوق
واقف بالامس كانت مكتظه تماما بالاجنبي
الطريقه كله سماوي والطريق كله اهازيج كله
مجسمات كل الاغاني والاناشيد الارجنتينيه
المعروفه مهاجمه الكل مهاجمه ايضا
وذكر خروج البرازيلي تحدي الكروات يعني
الحماس عالي جدا المشجع الارجنتيني يحضر
هنا للمسانده المنتخب كما هي عادته من
بدايه كاس العالم ايضا يحضر همم عمل ثاني
مشاهده اخر اخر كاس عالم ليونيل ميسي
الكوره العالمي والاسطوره الارجنتيني
المشجع الارجنتيني يثق في منتخب وكثير
يعني المنتخب المشجعه ارجنتينيه جلستنا
معاهم كثير نسالهم ايش سبب الحضور هم
يعشقون كره القدم رغم الازمه او الضائع
الماليه اللي يعيش فيها
الارجنتين والمشجع الارجنتين لانهم يحضرون
بكثافه بعائلات
ويسكنوا لعده ايام ويشاهده المباريات بكل
حماس وشجع الارجنتين ايضا يقطع 14,000
كيلو متر وهي ما يبعد بين الارجنتين وبين
منطقه الخليج العربي بكثافه لهذا لا
تستغربي من تواجد الجمهور الكبير في لوسيل
الذي تجاوز 80,000 اغلبه من المشجع
للجنتين يتكون كثيرا في منتخبهم خصوصا بعد
الفوز الكبير في المباراه الماضيه والفوز
والاكتساح امام هولندا هولندا القوي جدا
والمنظم جدا بقياده خان خالد
يعني كمان فقط
طائرات يوميه الى قطر ايضا لمتابعه مباراه
يوم غد التي ستكون بين المغرب وفرنسا
اليوم فهد بما انه نتحدث عن منتخبين غير
عربيات اين يقف العرب بين المنتخبين في
الدوحه اليوم
بالنسبه للارجنتين كرواتيا لا يميل
الارجنتين طبعا اكثر هناك العديد يعني حتى
من الاصدقاء في السعوديه
اصدقائي ايضا في الكويت في الامارات
بيسالوا عن التذاكر من بدايه تحديد
المباراه من بدايه التحديد المباراه
الارجنتين كرواتيا بيسالوا عن طريقه
الحصول على التذاكر هل يوجد تذاكر فاعتقد
انه ال- ال- المتابع العربي والمتابع
الخليجي بالتحديد باميل طبعا الارجنتين
بشكل اكبر طبعا هو يعمل بتكرار همم اول
شيء مشاهد ميسي واخر نسخه من ليونيل ميسي
ثاني تكرار الانجاز اللي حصل مع هذا الرجل
الراحل الاسطوره العظيم همم
مارادونا يريد ان يشاهدوا الكاس مره اخرى
همم بيد ليونيل ميسي هذا المسمى الذي وضع
هنا للراحل مارادونا اللي حتى ميسي يعني
بعد الفوز الاخير صرح تصريح يعني هو هو قد
يكون غريب علينا لكن عندهم عادي انه همم
مارادونا يشاهدنا وتصل لنا دعواته واتمنى
ان يستمر معنا حتى النهائي احنا نتمنى ان
شاء الله نشوف مستوى الارجنتين اللي صار
لنا مثل النهائي
ونشاهد ايضا همم كاس عالم اخرى همم بايدي
الارجنتين كما حمله ورماندو مارادونا وهذا
ههه وهذا قميصه
وهذا اخر قميص الديك ومارادونا همم في همم
كاس العالم 86 طبعا نتمنى المنتخب المغربي
اكيد اكيد العاطفه همم جياشه ومتجه
المنتخب المغربي لكن ايضا الارجنتين منتخب
كبير لها جمهور عظيم في كل انحاء العالم
خصوصا همم العرب
صباح العربيه شكرا جزيلا لهم الفوز
لارجنتين ههه
اما الان الى ابراهيم
انا بتمنى انه الاضعف يطلع للنهائي ويفوز
المغرب على فرنسا